der angebliche engste freund von
wladimir putin ironischerweise ein
ukraine millionenschwerer oligarch in
handschellen auf instagram vorgeführt
spektakulärer erfolg des ukrainischen
inlandsgeheimdienstes es bei diesem ist
es nach angaben von ukraine präsident
wurde mir slansky gelungen den ängsten
und einflussreichen verbündeten von
präsident wladimir putin
gefangenzunehmen selensky verbreitete
ein foto von mit wetzig bei instagram
dieses zeigt den putin vertrauten in
militärkleidung und in handschellen mit
wegzug war zuletzt auf der flucht befand
sich zuvor im hausarrest bevor er
untertauchte in seiner videoansprache
schlug selensky dann einen austausch mit
webshops gegen die ukraine in russischer
kriegsgefangenschaft vor
es ist sehr symbolisch dass er mit wett
stück am tag der kosmonauten
festgenommen wurde er hat sich 48 tage
lang versteckt aber schließlich
entschied er sich zu versuchen aus
unserem land zu fliehen nun für diesen
astronauten im schlechtesten sinne des
wortes hat es nicht geklappt ich finde
es besonders zynisch von ihm
militärische kleidung zu verwenden er
hat versucht sich zu verkleiden was für
ein soldat was für ein patriot nun wenn
mit wegzug sich eine militäruniform
ausgesucht hat fällt er auch unter die
regeln des kriegsrechts ich schlage der
russischen föderation daher vor ihren
jungen ging unsere jungen mädchen in
russischer gefangenschaft
auszutauschen daher ist es wichtig dass
unsere strafverfolgungsbehörden um das
militär diese möglichkeit ebenfalls in
betracht ziehen
mit web shop wird auch agentes kreml
genannt er gilt als putins bester freund
steht im verdacht verdeckt als schatten
ein thema drei pro russische tv sammlern
zu kontrollieren putin soll sogar
taufpate der jüngsten tochter des
oligarchen seien gegen mit wetzig läuft
in der ukraine bereits ein verfahren
wegen starts war darauf stehen bis zu 15
jahre haft jetzt könnte es also zu einem
spektakulären austausch kommen
sprechen wir mit unserem reporter
philipp fiat offen in mikro allen der
ukraine über diesen olli gagen der ja
wie gesagt ironischerweise ukrainer ist
und trotzdem ein enger freund von putin
wie passt das zusammen philipp
tja das zeigt was für ein verhältnis
diese beiden länder einmal hat nun damit
meine ich kein gutes rechnung sondern
ein sehr unheilvolles verhältnis
da bleibt das bild gerade ein bisschen
stehen aber das haben sie schon öfter
gehabt wenn wir in die ukraine schalten
und da bewegst du dich auch schon wieder
philipp vielleicht kannst nicht die
antwort gleich noch mal ehrlich wie
passt das zusammen
ja ich habe gesagt das ist zeigt was für
ein unheilvolles verhältnisses lange gab
zwischen russland der ukraine putin
hatte hier sehr viele einfluss agenten
bis hoch zum vergangenen zum letzten
nähe zum vorletzten präsidenten viktor
janukowitsch der versucht hat das land
in russische abhängigkeit zu treiben
also die kreml agenten waren hier
überall und seit jahren werden sie auch
verfolgt mit wittstock ist jetzt das
beste beispiel und das sorgt hier in der
ukraine wirklich gute laune dass ein so
enger verbündeter ein so enger
persönlicher freund von putin jetzt vom
spd vom ukrainischen sicherheitsdienst
gefasst werden konnte du sagst es gut
sorgt für gute laune es ist natürlich
auch ein propagandamittel
absolut natürlich es geht hier auch
darum die kampfmoral zu steigern auf der
einen seite deswegen ganz viele ukrainer
hatten natürlich dieses foto auf ihrem
handy und haben sich sehr darüber
gefreut auf der anderen seite geht es
natürlich auch darum ein zeichen an all
die anderen zu senden die sich mit putin
verbündet haben die auch im hintergrund
versucht haben diesen vor diesem krieg
etwas zu organisieren auf die beine zu
stellen mit wenn die russischen truppen
hier kommen damit städten hier auf
glücklich werden damit ganze bezirke den
russen übergeben werden all diese leute
ist das ein zeichen wir haben den
mächtigsten von euch geschnappt und euch
kriegen wir auch
du bist in den micro das ist die
viertgrößte stadt in der ukraine eine
millionenstadt fast eine million
einwohner heute kam die nachricht schon
dort dass das russische militär die
leichen von
1500 soldaten in der stadt russischen
soldaten einfach zurückgelassen habe ist
das vorstellbar
das ist das was mir auch am telefon der
stellvertretende bürgermeister der stadt
gesagt hat was scheint tatsächlich zu
sein und das entspricht auch was man
bislang über die russische kriegsführung
gehört hat und zwar nämlich dass die
russen viel lieber ukrainische
autos ukrainische kühlschränke und
waschmaschinen mit nehmen anstatt die
leichen ihrer soldaten die werden
oftmals einfach auf dem schlachtfeld
zurückgelassen und werden wohl jetzt
hier in die pro gelagert 1500 das sagt
glaube ich sehr viel wie vielen menschen
leben heute im heutigen russland wert
ist wie ist die stimmung in der stadt
den micro nachdem sich ja jetzt die
russischen angriffe mehr auf den osten
konzentrieren du warst vorher für uns ja
wochenlang in lemberg ganz im westen
wenn du das jetzt mal vergleicht und die
situation sind sie tritt da ein bisschen
von entspannung eingehen die leute auch
wieder auf die straße weil sie wissen
dass die angriffe sich eher auf andere
ziele konzentrieren
also man weiß natürlich dass der
hauptfokus der russen auf dem don bass
gericht wird aber ehrlich gesagt nie pro
macht sich auch auf eine offensive
bekannt denn genau das haben die
amerikanischen geheimdienste prophezeit
metro legt ja auch an der zentrale osten
keine und ist sozusagen die letzte große
stadt im osten bevor es dann nach ihr
frei gehört das heißt man erwartet hier
eine offensive und man ist darauf
vorbereitet die front ist jetzt ca 100
kilometer südlich südlich von der stadt
sa borussia man erwartet nicht das mikro
irgendwie eingenommen werden kann weil
hier der nachrichten ist ein wirklich
gewaltiger schluss dass diese stadt kann
man gut verteidigen also man erwartet
eine offensive und man erwartet auch
viel mehr raketenangriffe in den
kommenden tagen und wochen